even old wolf still bite in its third
year destiny is finally trying to
explore the myths that have pervaded its
world since launch the rise of iron
expansion rings a new storyline with
fantasy elements more cooperative
strikes additional public events an
assortment of player versus player
offerings and a new upcoming multiplayer
raid in short rise of iron attempts to
dig beneath the surface of bungees
post-apocalyptic world at this time
though the expansion has yet to go very
deep there are mented with some sort of
technology footsteps rise of iron
explores the tale of the iron Lords the
order of warriors that fought before the
post-apocalyptic world evolved into
destiny as we know it now the expansion
draws heavy influences from Game of
Thrones and Lord of the Rings wolves
live sprawl across the stone floors of
fellow winter peak characters dawn pelts
to cross snowy mountain sides and
ancient evils return from the past to
wreak havoc on the present as a
portmanteau of fantasy and science
fiction the setup is promising but the
writing doesn't lend the premise much
momentum characters are one-dimensional
and the plot whisks by without conveying
the weight of your missions the taken
King destinies previous expansion showed
promise in the way it depicted the
nuanced personalities of its lone
warriors after finishing rise of irons
90-minute storyline I feel as if destiny
has taken a narrative step back
the actual quest line show a little more
promise although emissions frequently
retread locales from destiny's first two
years and firefights can become
repetitive there are a few standouts
most notably a skirmish that plays out
in the shadows of massive anti-aircraft
guns and a boss fight that encourages
melee combat throughout rising iron may
exhibit the same signs of combat fatigue
that a permeated destiny since launch
but right now it has a few shining
moments of stellar design the new
cooperative strikes show the same
paralysis between the past and future
one of the strikes is a rehash version
of one of Destiny's earliest boss fights
and it makes few attempts to hide the
fact the actual new strike on the other
hand pits you against an ogre impervious
to damage forcing you to dodge is
pummeling attacks while you eliminate
his leader yoga is a constant threat
that disrupts the objective creating
tension without becoming overly invasive
with its second major expansion destiny
still knows how to craft a thrilling
boss fight I have yet to spend more than
two hours with Destiny's new supremacy
mode and multiplayer maps but from what
I've played there is nothing novel here
the maps mostly comprised close quarters
hallways and catwalks of varying
elevations supremacy also lacks
inspiration after killing an opponent
you don't get full credit for the
elimination until you collect the orbit
leaves behind this mode has been done
before in numerous other shooters and
while it rewards risky maneuvers and
daring Sprint's into the open it quickly
feels wrote their glory goes to you got
him
as of now the prevailing sentiment is a
time playing rise of iron just for the
feeling of progress and few genuine
thrills but my final opinion all hinges
on the expansion's late-game quest lines
and of course it's six person raid I'll
be further increasing my light level
over the next few days completing more
quests in the rise of iron lineup and
preparing for the raid time will tell if
this cooperative battle can mitigate my
lukewarm response
you